imposible imaginar un mejor comienzo
para wallite regrae que llegó a la
cabeza de la selección marroquia apenas
tres meses antes del puntapié inicial
del mundial a su llegada Los Leones del
Atlas han dado un giro desde entonces se
ha multiplicado las hazañas venciendo a
gigantes europeos como Portugal España y
Bélgica
puedes tener menos talento menos
cualidades menos dinero pero si quieres
si trabajas si luchas Si crees puedes
creo que todo el mundo está ahora del
lado de Marruecos Ojalá
walice grahaggy es un Franco marroquí
hizo la mayor parte de su carrera en
Francia y obtuvo allí sus diplomas de
entrenador entre 2001 y 2009 también
jugó 45 veces con Marruecos en 2012 su
país de origen le ofreció su primer
trabajo como técnico una estrategia que
valió la pena 10 años después Hoy es el
primer entrenador en llevar a un equipo
africano hasta semifinales de un mundial
hasta ahora hacemos feliz a nuestro
pueblo hacemos feliz a un continente
hacemos feliz al árabe creo que sabes un
poco cuando miras a Rocky Balboa quiere
ser Rocky porque él es el que viene de
abajo Así que aquí estamos un poco como
Rocky en este mundial
de los 26 jugadores del equipo 14
nacieron fuera de Marruecos
fundamentalmente en Países Bajos Bélgica
España y también en Francia esa Francia
a la que los Leones del Atlas se
enfrentarán el miércoles en semifinales
quizás el último paso antes de alcanzar
su sueño el de llegar a la final del
mundial de fútbol